la question de départ dans les
recherches de sciences économiques et
sociales la ressource qui est à la base
de cet exposé le manuel de recherches en
sciences sociales de luc van kampen out
et raymond qui vit cette vidéo on
reviendra sur la démarche des sciences
sociales posera la question de pourquoi
une question de départ et puis abordera
les trois critères à respecter pour
avoir une bonne question de départ à
savoir la clarté la faisabilité et la
pertinence
pour rappel voici la démarche des
sciences sociales
il y a donc sept étapes à respecter mais
qui vont influencer les unes les autres
c'est à dire que c'est pas vraiment un
processus totalement linéaire il ya
toujours des retours qui se font et der
précision qui se font sur les étapes qui
sont passés nous il ya tout d'abord
cette question de départ qui est très
importante puisque c'est vraiment la
porte d'entrée de la de la recherche qui
va déboucher sur une exploration qui
elle-même va permettre de définir
clairement une problématique dans
laquelle nous allons construire un
modèle d' analyse sur lequel nous allons
nous appuyer pour observer la réalité
économique et sociale
cette observation évidemment débouchera
sur une analyse des résultats qui
permettront de conclure la recherche
la question de départ va vraiment être
la porte d'entrée de la recherche
souvent les objets les thèmes qui vont
être abordés en sciences sociales sont
vastes et donc pour éviter de se perdre
dans la matière et de finalement faire
un travail qui n'a ni queue ni tête et
qui ne fait qu'accumuler les différents
qu'on a on va vraiment se poser une
question à laquelle on va tenter de
répondre via bien sûr une hypothèse et
une observation
tous les grands auteurs de sciences
sociales ont utilisé des questions de
départ pour leurs travaux que ce soit
les travaux et plus prestigieux ou ceux
qui sont un petit peu passées sous
silence
tout d'abord raymond boudon par exemple
dans l'inégalité des chances va se poser
la question est ce que l'inégalité des
chances devant l'enseignement
à telle tendance à décroître dans les
sociétés industrielles pierre bourdieu
en collaboration avec alain d'arbel va
lui se poser la question de caisse qui
prédisposent certains à fréquenter les
musées
contrairement à la grande majorité de
ceux qui ne fréquentent pas voyez les
questions sont à la fois très courtes
très simple mais elles vont donner
naissance dans ces cas-ci à des
recherches qui auront vraiment une
influence très importante sur les
sciences sociales
jusqu'à présent les quels sont les
critères d'une bonne question de départ
il ya trois types de critères à
respecter les critères de clarté les
qualités de faisabilité et la pertinence
de la question la question de départ
doit répondre à un critère de clarté
c'est à dire qu'elle doit être courte et
précise c'est à dire claire mais en même
temps rester suffisamment ouvertes pour
permettre un développement
voici quelques exemples de questions qui
ne répondent pas à ce qu'ils libèrent de
clarté et qui sont donc des contre
exemples
je vous laisse les parcourir la première
en fait est beaucoup trop vague parce
que je ne vois pas dans quand je parle
par exemple de la vie des habitants de
quoi il s'agit est-ce que c'est des
notions de mobilité de mixité sociale
quand anton par cette vie des habitants
oui c'est beaucoup trop vague il
faudrait vraiment repréciser chacun des
termes la seconde proposition quand elle
est encore trop vagues allaient beaucoup
plus précises dans le sens où on voit
bien où on veut en venir les différents
termes sont suffisamment claires les
concepts sont bien définis par eux-mêmes
mais on les causes de la diminution des
emplois c'est très vague
on peut rentrer là dedans dans une
recherche vraiment qui va être trop
importante et qui ne va finalement ne
répondre rien du tout donc là il
faudrait canaliser un petit peu et
préciser quel type de critère ou quel
type de cause on veut identifier
enfin la dernière
je me permets de la lyre dans quelle
mesure le souci de maintenir l'emploi
dans le secteur de la construction
explique-t-il la décision d'entreprendre
de grands projets de travaux publics
destiné non seulement à soutenir ce
secteur mais aussi à diminuer les
risques de conflits sociaux
si vous avez compris cette question en
une seule fois sans devoir la relire
bien c'est que ce n'est pas une excuse
est très fort mais en tout cas cette
question si vous devez la relire de ces
mauvaises questions d'une question
recherche quelque chose de cours ou qui
permet de voir directement où on veut en
venir
la question de départ doit être aussi
faisable c'est à dire elle doit être
réaliste et que la démarche qui va
suivre va être réalisable un exemple ici
de questions qui débouche sur une
recherche qui va demander énormément de
temps et d'argent parce qu'évidemment
vous allez devoir vous déplacer l ai
rencontré les différents chefs
d'entreprise dans l'union européenne ce
qui n'est pas possible si vous avez un
budget limité et encore plus bon ben si
vous êtes élèves dans le secondaire
de la même façon si vous voulez faire
une recherche sur une tribu perdue dans
le fin fond de l'amazonie ben voilà il
faut prévoir ou un d'oublier d'aller
d'avion pour y aller et revenir
donc il ya tout d'abord ces critères de
logistique
est-ce que c'est faisable à ce qu'on en
a les moyens mais aussi ce qu'on en a
les moyens intellectuels est ce que je
suis suffisamment calais dans ce domaine
là pour entreprendre cette démarche
c'est la raison pour laquelle beaucoup
de chercheurs finalement reste toujours
cantonné aux mêmes objets d'étude et
reste un petit peu toujours sur les
mêmes sujets parce qu'il est difficile à
120 avant de se réinvestir dans un
nouveau thème dernier critère la
pertinence c'est vraiment ce critère là
qui va permettre de dire si on est dans
une démarche qui est orientée par une
vision scientifique parce qu'ici la
question de départ doit forcément
déboucher sur une explication à ne doit
pas être descriptive donc descriptif
c'est juste dire ce que c'est elle ne
doit pas être normani normative normatif
ça veut dire ce qui doit être
et elle doit être sans jugement de
valeur le jugement de valeur c'est ce
qui est bien
et mal voici quelques exemples de
questions qui ne répondent pas ce
critère de pertinence
la manière dont la fiscalité est
organisé dans le pays étaient
socialement juste
là il ya vraiment une connotation morale
jugement de valeur de ce qui est juste
ce qui est pas juste ce n'est pas une
question qui est à la base d'une
démarche scientifique
les patrons explique-t-il les
travailleurs ben voilà la réponse est
quasi quasi dans la question
on sent claque le chercheur veut
directement répondu oui et va argumenter
en faveur de sa vision des choses on
voit que là c'est tout à fait une vision
partielle d'une problématique
la fraude fiscale est une des causes du
dif du déficit de l'état
c'est encore une fois trop orienté et
trop normatif on pourrait étudier le
déficit de l'état mais landelies
directement un phénomène un autre on
oriente trop la question et on ne va pas
expliquer réellement des phénomènes qui
existent
quels changements affecteront
l'organisation de l'enseignement d'ici
une vingtaine d'années
impossible à dire donc on ne va pas être
dans une explication on va être plutôt
dans une production est donc plutôt une
opinion que réellement une explication
d'un phénomène s'est réellement
difficile pour des élèves de secondaire
de ne pas faire de travail des travaux
descriptif d'être explicatif la seule
façon de réellement rentrer dans une
démarche explicative ça sera plus tard
de bien construire le modèle d'analysé
évidemment voilà sept ans faisant qu'on
apprend dont je vous propose ici que
peut-être essayer de trouver d'ici le
prochain cours quelques questions de
départ qui pourrait vous mener vers une
recherche pour un travail en sciences
sociales ou en sciences économiques ou
voir même en géographie et nous les
amènerons ensemble pour voir si elles
répondent bien aux différents critères
que nous avons annoncés ici je vous
remercie et à bientôt